[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're discussing s Snape Lord Voldemort
and the massive question of why on Earth
Snape didn't do more to stagnate
Voldemort's Resurgence as the series
unfolds snap's loyalties and motivations
become a subject of intense speculation
and debate among fans because you see
throughout the series Snape occupies a
unique position situated at the
crossroads of light and darkness
initially portrayed as a villain his
true Allegiance is later revealed
however upon this big reveal I couldn't
help but also ask why didn't he
capitalize on an opportunity to
eliminate Voldemort sooner Snape had
fooled everyone even the legilimens Lord
Voldemort which put him in a better
position to assassinate Voldemort than
than anyone sure Voldemort's HW ruxers
would have kept him alive but he would
have been once again reduced to a
non-corporeal form reliant on others
like nagini and pettigru to help him
return to a physical form another aspect
to consider is that the more time
Voldemort is reduced to a non-corporeal
form the more time there is to find and
destroy the rest of his HW rxes in this
scenario it's entirely possible that by
the time Voldemort is back he has no
more HW ruxers to fall back back on by
killing Voldemort Snape could have
effectively put Voldemort's Resurgence
to a halt and potentially saved
countless lives in the process and all
it would have taken is one surprise of
AR kadavra so was it unwillingness fear
snap's Devotion to a grander plan or
something else altogether let's dive in
actually pulling it off the first thing
we need to consider is that an
assassination attempt is no easy task
particularly on the dark lord himself
who surrounds himself with Keen
protective and loyal Death Eaters it
would be risky even for Snape and there
is always the chance that Voldemort
could have seen the attack coming
Voldemort is a master at legilimency
which is the art of magically navigating
the mind of another extracting their
feelings and memories Snape does happen
to be a master oans which means that he
is able to close his mind off to
legitimacy and very effectively at that
but here's the thing killing someone
particularly with the killing curse
requires an abundance of emotion and
it's hard to imagine that a master legil
like Voldemort wouldn't detect it the
Snape was able to trick the death
heaters for years but he always tread
carefully stepping out of line and
plotting to kill Voldemort with an
unforgivable curse is another story all
together the following excerpts from the
text describe the emotion required to
cast the killing curse aad kadav is a
curse that needs a powerful bit of magic
behind it you could all get your ones
out now and point them at me and say the
words and I doubt i' get so much as a
nose bleed but that doesn't matter I'm
not here to teach you how to do it never
used an unforgivable curse before have
you boy she yelled she had abandoned her
baby voice now you need to mean them
Potter you need to really want to cause
pain to enjoy it righteous anger won't
hurt me for long I'll show you how it's
done shall I so my theory is that
mustering up the necessary emotions
required to cast the killing curse would
be noticed by Voldemort making the
mission unbelievably dangerous if s and
Dumbledore had felt that this was
plausible then I'm sure they would have
gone ahead with it sooner ease of return
the next thing we need to consider is
that if Voldemort had been brought back
to a physical form once it could easily
be replicated again and likely even
faster than before after re
aievoli in the graveyard to his Death
Eaters about how it was done the first
time he lost his corporeal form things
were a bit more dire and that's why it
took so long I remember only forcing
myself sleeplessly endlessly second by
second to exist I settled in a far away
place in a forest and I waited surely
one of my faithful Death Eaters would
try and find me one of them would come
and perform the magic I could not to
restore me to a body but I waited in
vain however thanks to wormtail and
Voldemort's knowledge of a potion that
would be able to help him achieve a
corporeal form once again he was able to
accomplish his goal but I was willing to
embrace mortal life again before chasing
immortality I set my sight slower I
would settle for my old body back again
and my old strength I knew that to
achieve this it is an old piece of dark
magic the potion that revived me tonight
I would need three powerful ingredients
well one of them was already at hand was
it not wormtail flesh given by a servant
my father's bone naturally that meant we
would have to come here where he was
buried but the blood of a foe wormtail
would have had me use any wizard would
you not wormtail any any wizard who had
hated me as so many of them still do but
I knew the one I must use if I was to
rise again more powerful than I had been
when I had fallen I wanted Harry
Potter's blood I wanted the blood of the
one who would Strip Me of power 13 years
ago but the lingering protection his
mother once gave him would then reside
in my veins too because the death
heaters now knew how easy it was for
Voldemort to once again assume a
physical form it's unlikely that Snape
would act impulsively and kill Voldemort
because what would it achieve the first
time took many many years but if he
could now return to his physical form in
a week would it really be worth it for
Snape to blow his cover compromising his
role as a double agent Snape was a
double agent which means that for the
duration of the books and films Snape's
loyalties was still very much unclear to
many both sides thought that they had an
ally but we later find out that despite
his dubious past Snape is good all along
this means that he likely would have had
many opportunities to attack Voldemort
however if the attack on Voldemort was
unsuccessful or if killing Voldemort
ultimately only had a marginal impact on
his Resurgence then losing the Dark
Lord's trust could have been very
dangerous as a double agent and part of
Voldemort's Inner Circle Snape had
access to all sorts of vital
intelligence that allowed him to
potentially save lives it's entirely
possible that a futile attempt on
Voldemort's life would have only severed
his access to Vital Information and
ultimately cost more lives in the long
run furthermore one of snap's primary
motivations throughout the series was
protecting Harry Potter any premature
action that jeopardized snapes cover
could have indirectly put Harry at risk
without snap's guidance and protection
the order would have been more
vulnerable to Voldemort's attacks and
manipulation the final hwr the final
reason that Snape didn't kill Voldemort
is that his final hwr the hwr inside of
Harry needed to be destroyed by
Voldemort himself tell him that on the
night Lord Voldemort tried to kill him
when Lily cast her own life between them
as a shield the killing curse rebounded
upon Lord Voldemort and a fragment of
Voldemort's Soul was blasted apart from
the hole and latched itself onto the
only living Soul left in that collapsing
building part of Lord Voldemort lives
inside Harry and it is that which gives
him the power of speech with snakes and
a connection with Lord Voldemort's mind
that he has never understood and while
that fragment of soul and missed by
Voldemort remains attached to and
protected by Harry Lord Voldemort cannot
die Harry seemed to be watching the two
men from one end of a long tunnel they
were so far away from him their voices
echoing strangely in his ears so The Boy
The Boy Must Die asked Snape quite
calmly and Voldemort himself must do it
seus that is essential for Voldemort to
be properly destroyed it was essential
that Voldemort himself be the one to
destroy his final HW crugs which meant
that it was imperative that he maintains
a physical form of some kind if snake
had killed Voldemort prematurely it
would have only delayed the inevitable
additionally despite being on the inner
circle of both sides of the battle Snape
is still very much unaware of a lot of
the things happening behind the scenes
he doesn't know about the relationship
between Harry and the HW cruxes and this
is because Dumbledore had been very
vague when discussing plans with him the
Snape also doesn't know about the
connection between Harry and Voldemort
as a result of Lily's sacrifice all he
knows is that Dumbledore made it
abundantly clear that Voldemort would
have to be the one to kill Harry
conclusion while the idea of Snape
assassinating Voldemort might hold an
initial appeal it is unlikely that such
an act would have yielded a lasting
victory for the good side in reality the
complex dynamics of Voldemort's
immortality and the intricate Strategies
employed by Snape in the Order of the
Phoenix ultimately played a more pivotal
role inv Voldemort's ultimate downfall
Snape killing him may have bought a bit
of time but how much a week he would
have risked his life cut ties with the
Death Eaters and Voldemort would have
been back again in a corporeal form in
no time at all additionally with
Voldemort's corporeal form gone the hwrs
and Harry would have lived on only
further perpetuating Voldemort's
existence while a compelling thought
snap's actions in this scenario would
have ultimately been futile and that's
it for this video what do you guys think
leave a comment down below also if you
enjoy the content please like the video
And subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
live